vielleicht haben sie einen der schönsten
arbeitsplätze der welt die ranger rinnen
rund um den amboseli nationalpark
sie nennen sich das team lyoness das
lügen team und wie löwen haben lea und
ihre kolleginnen lange darum gekämpft
als frauen dahin zu kommen wo die männer
schon längst waren als massa einen
eigenen job zu haben konflikte zwischen
menschen und tieren zu lösen auf
patrouille wilde tiere zu orten und zu
erfassen und zu beweisen frauen die
lehrer können das genauso gut
[Musik]
in unseren dörfern haben wir unsere
träume getötet und uns gesagt dass es
den männern vorbehalten seit ich hierher
gekommen bin und mit meinen kolleginnen
ermutigt wurde sage ich ich kann das
schaffen
bis zu 30 km laufen die frauen jeden tag
immer in der hitze gerade jetzt ist
dürrezeit und die masai sind gezwungen
ihre herden außerhalb der dörfer weiden
zu lassen immer wieder kommt es zu
angriffen von wildtieren auch auf
menschen
wenn die dörfer in der gemeinde von der
dürre heimgesucht werden sind wir
gezwungen der gemeinde zu erlauben ihr
vieh zum füttern zu bringen so wie diese
hier die von weiter weg kommen sie
lassen ihre kühe hier weiden weil es bei
ihnen keine weite mehr gibt
einmal im monat kehren die frauen zu
ihren familien zurück in die
traditionellen
für lea bedeutet dass nicht nur glück
die 21 jährige wurde von ihrer mutter
ermutigt sich zu bewerben die hat nie
eigenes geld gehabt musste immer leas
vater fragen
es ist gut weil sie um nichts mehr
bitten muss und frei ist das zu tun was
sie will
für die frauen in ihrem dorf ist lea ein
vorbild doch hier gilt was ihr vater
sagt und so wird aus der ranger in lea
schnell wieder die massai frau lia ihr
vater will es obwohl sie mit ihrem
einkommen zum wohlstand der ganzen
gemeinde beiträgt zu hause muss sie tun
was das familienoberhaupt verlangt
[Musik]
wenn einmal sei man dich sieht und du
bist attraktiv dann geht er morgens zu
deinem haus und er sagt dem vater er
will dich heiraten aus den und den
gründen und da der vater der chef der
familie ist musst du das befolgen
na ja versucht zu verdrängen und eine
entscheidung herauszuzögern von ihrem
ersten gehalt hat sie der familie eine
ziege geschenkt vor allem aber hat sie
sich damit zeit gekauft und die familie
erst einmal gefestigt
den kampf zwischen tradition und moderne
hat junis bereits hinter sich und sich
für den job entschieden sie ist die
einzige ihres ganzen dorfes und auch des
teams die einen führerschein hat auch
das ist ein meilenstein für ihre
kolleginnen dass junis einen großen
geländewagen fährt dafür bewundert sie
ihre familie schließlich doch
[Musik]
minute das bedeutet mir sehr viel weil
das eine veränderung in unserer
gemeinschaft ist zum beispiel haben wir
hier einige männer die mich sehen wenn
ich ins auto steige sie sehen mich in
der position des fahrers und sie fragen
sich ist es die frau die fahren kann in
meiner gemeinde ist das etwas sehr
großes etwas überrascht es weil sie
sagen wird sogar eine frau kann fahren
schon wenige minuten später ist ihr
fahrkönnen gefragt das team lines muss
zum nächsten einsatz hirten haben sie
gerufen eine elefantenherde hat für eine
gemeinde angegriffen hektik kommt
überlegen die sängerinnen müssen die
tiere aus dem unwegsamen gelände auf
eine freie fläche treiben die elefanten
wollen ein kleines nur eine woche altes
baby beschützen fühlen sich in die enge
getrieben
die frauen müssen nerven bewahren auch
als die elefanten mutter plötzlich
aggressiv wird
das team leidet ihre weg von den dörfern
in sicherheit bringen damit die
einwohner ihnen nichts anhaben können
also oft kam es zu vergeltungsaktionen
[Musik]
purity ist stolz der einsatz ist
geglückt
unseren größten herausforderungen ist
der konflikt zwischen menschen und
tieren denn wenn ihr vieh angegriffen
wird versuchen sie die wilden tiere auch
löwen und hyänen zu vergiften sie
versuchen sie zu vergiften was wir dann
normalerweise tun ist ihnen die
bedeutung der wildtiere zu erklären
auch in diesen traditionellen massa auf
dem sogenannten puma hat in der nacht
ein löwe ein tier gerissen die ranger
rinnen wollen wissen was genau passiert
ist insgesamt 16 frauen arbeiten bei
team lynas sie wurden ausgewählt von
ihrem glanz zum ersten mal wird jetzt
auch mit den frauen in den dörfern
gesprochen und sie werden gefragt wie es
ihnen geht und die frauen sind stolz auf
sie
das ist der wandel weil sie die gleiche
arbeit wie die männer machen deshalb
wären ihre eltern wir frauen nicht mehr
leiden weil wir unsere mädchen da
hingebracht haben
diejenigen die keine arbeit haben lieben
das wenn sie diese arbeit machen weil
sie andere mit nach oben ziehen
schon die grüne uniform der truppe macht
einen unterschied
männerkleidung thiel aka ist 24 jahre
alt noch nie hat eine frau aus ihrer
gemeinde ein eigenes gehalt bekommen sie
ist die erste
ich bin immer noch eine masse frau
nichts hat sich in mir geändert was sich
geändert hat ist dass ich jetzt mehr
power habe wenn ich nach hause gehe
kleide ich mich wie sie und ich tue das
was sie tun und danach gehe ich wieder
an die arbeit und kleide mich wie eine
managerin
der amboseli nationalpark liegt im süden
kenias an der grenze zu tansania
amboseli bedeutet in der masai sprache
so viel wie salziger staub graslandes
savanne aber auch sumpfes wechseln sich
ab
heimat der elefanten so wird der
ambrosie die auch genannt etwa 800 leben
hier und im gegensatz zu tieren in
anderen reservaten verlassen nur die
wenigsten den ambrosini
vielleicht auch weil es ungewöhnlich
viel wasser gibt ein drittel des parks
vom amboseli sie bedeckt ist
vor allem aber ist der amboseli für
seine postkarten idylle bekannt den
freien blick auf den kilimandscharo den
höchsten berg afrikas
am nächsten morgen 6 uhr team lynas
macht sich fit für den tag wir hier
arbeiten will muss gut trainiert sein
und abitur haben das sind die
voraussetzungen
junis etwa war profi läuferinnen weit
weg vom amboseli bevor sie zum löwen
team stieß sie verließ ihren freund und
erfüllte sich ihren traum
mein ganzes leben wollte ich ringerin
werden denn als ich in der highschool
war wollte ich unbedingt diese grüne
uniform tragen als dann die
ausschreibung kam und ich mich an die
uniform erinnerte die ich wirklich
tragen wollte habe ich mich entschlossen
mich zu bewerben und zu schauen ob ich
es schaffe theresa drei wochen am stück
leben die frauen hier mitten in der
wildnis in zwei oder drei bett zimmern
weit weg von ihren familien im camp
leben sie nicht die masai frauen sind es
nicht kochen sich nicht um die familie
kümmern im gegenteil hier steht ein mann
am herd oder besser an der feuerstelle
er muss ich schon herausforderungen
bestehen meine freunde fragen warum ich
als man gerne für folgend woche aber ich
finde es sehr interessant für frauen zu
machen
purity und eunice koordinieren auch die
teams im bild reservat wo wurden welche
tiere gesichtet und welche masse dörfern
gibt es probleme wie er braucht hilfe
20.000 kenia schilling etwa 160 euro
verdienen die frauen im schnitt auch für
kenia nicht viel geld doch das ist nicht
was sie motiviert
sagt das war mein traum als ich jung war
und diese leidenschaft die ich für
wildtiere hege diese liebe die ich für
wildtiere higl treiben mich an diesen
job zu machen nicht aufzugeben immer
weiter zu versuchen und sicherzustellen
dass ich es schaffe
es ist ein schwerer weg für die 16
frauen vom team lynas ist einen schritt
heraus zu schaffen aus der tradition der
gemeinschaften andere frauen zu
bestärken und sich selbst ein stückchen
freiheit zu erkämpfen
[Musik]